ce sont pratiquement battus pour Zelda
ils auraient vraiment enfin sûrement
d'expression ils auraient tué père et
mère pour Zelda et la coupable la voici
Zelda princesses du pays d'Hyrule ne
s'agit pas elle dans tous les sens c'est
à son faux chevalier link de la libérer
en déjouant les plans du prince des
voleurs Ganon ce jeu quête du Graal
moderne a nécessité un travail
considérable
il y a eu énormément de moyens qui ont
été mis derrière le développement de ce
jeu 300 personnes y ont travaillé sous
la direction de ce qui sans doute le
maître incontesté en matière de
développement de jeux vidéo qui
s'appelle monsieur Miyamoto qui a été
comparé au Spielberg du marché du jeu
vidéo pour sa réalisation et parce qu'il
était attendu depuis plus de deux ans le
jeu s'arrache littéralement avec 5
millions d'exemplaires vendus dans le
monde dont 200 000 en France depuis sa
sortie il y a dix jours c'est même la
pénurie dans les rayons
on a attendu pendant des mois il a fallu
six magasins pour l'avoir c'était en
rupture de stock partout